All right. Uh, welcome back everybody.
Uh, today's topic is going to be about
content delivery networks, also known as
CDNs for short. Um, these should be
pretty important to all of you because
considering that all of us software
engineers watch probably 3 to 6 hours of
day. They've probably completely
revolutionized the speed of that. So,
you know, you've got something to thank
CDN's for. But anyways, let's get into
this video. It should be a pretty quick
one and then we can keep moving on to
more cool topics.
Okay, so content delivery networks or
CDN for short. So basically the point is
in most large scale websites or systems,
they have a ton of static content that
they want to be serving to their users.
Static content includes any file that
basically isn't going to be frequently
changing or you know appended to or
truncated. So that's things like HTML
files for certain pages of a website,
images and video content that users tend
to upload and basically just any other
file that generally is written once and
that doesn't really have to be modified.
However, the thing with these files is,
you know, obviously compared to just
like a row of data in a database,
they're pretty large and as a result,
it's going to take a really long time to
serve them from our application server.
And additionally, it takes a lot of load
on our application server to be able to
actually go fetch those from probably
some sort of underlying data store and
then go ahead and serve them to the end
user. So, as a result, basically what we
want to use is something called a
content delivery network or a CDN. And
I'll kind of explain how that makes this
process much better in a little bit. But
first, before we do that, let's just
talk about storing static content in
general. I didn't really want to devote
a full video to this because truthfully,
I'm not sure that it even requires a
full video, but basically speaking,
whenever you're dealing with storing
static content in something like a
systems design interview problem, you
should always just go ahead and say
you're going to use an object store.
Now, most channels will basically just
say use an object store. But in this
video, I'm going to do my best to
explain it. Uh, generally speaking,
object stores are something like AWSS3,
Azure Blob Storage, or uh Google Cloud
Storage. So the reason that we would use
something like an object store as
opposed to you know something like a
distributed file system like HDFS is
mainly that it is going to be much
cheaper and much more scalable and
potentially even faster. So let's
explain why that might happen. Well,
first of all uh unlike in HDFS uh object
stores have a flat structure which means
that you're just using keys and values
for those files as opposed to putting
them in a whole directory hierarchy. Um,
what this means is that basically you
can go ahead and use something like a
consistent hashing method to go ahead
and find those files or write those
files. So you don't need something like
a centralized name node like Hadoop
tends to use. This is going to obviously
speed up reads and writes a little bit.
In addition to the fact that there are
weaker guarantees on these object stores
such that you can't do things like
atomic renames of files and as a result
of that it means that there aren't going
to be any locks on files. you don't
really have any um you know concurrency
guarantees in the sense that if a new
version of a file is written it's just
going to have a higher version number.
There's no potential for you to just
like read a file and it's only half
updated. So you don't really have to
worry about atomicity but there's also
no locking which does make things a
little bit faster. Additionally, the
bigger reason that these object stores
are more scalable is the fact that you
only pay for the storage storage that
you use. Um, since we're using a cloud
environment here, you can basically just
be like, give me more hard drives.
Whereas, if you're running your own
Hadoop cluster, you probably have to run
it on more physical CPUs in addition to
hard drives as well. And what that
basically means is that your compute and
your storage are scaling linearly with
one another. Um, there are a couple of
downsides to these object stores. Um, so
the first one is basically going to be
that you can't do multiobject
transactions. If you want to do
something like that, you probably need
to use something like two-phase commit
or perhaps even a coordination service.
I'm actually not even sure that
two-phase commit would be built in. So
probably instead what you might have to
do is do one of the writes, check if it
succeeded, then do the second. But
obviously that that runs into a lot of
issues too. So maybe something like a
coordination service. Honestly, I'm not
even sure. But if you do want to run
something like batch jobs and streaming,
um, object stores might not be the best
thing for you. The reason for that being
they are solely meant to actually just
be holding immutable files. So if you
want to actually go ahead and run some
analytics on them, generally speaking,
you have to go ahead and copy those
files over to a Hadoop cluster or some
sort of cluster of nodes that can
actually support batch or streaming
jobs. And as a result, you lose that
data locality that is so useful in
Hadoop because you first have to copy
over all the files over the network
before you can actually start performing
that compute logic. As a result, that's
going to take a ton of time. So, it is
less efficient for doing that. But
generally speaking, these object stores
are going to be cheaper and more
scalable. So, that's the reason that
people tend to use them for static
content.
Generally speaking though, even though,
like I said, they're decently fast,
object stores probably aren't good
enough for you. If you're a huge website
like Google or you know YouTube or Tik
Tok, you're going to have users all over
the globe and you don't really want to
just be hammering your servers with all
these repeated requests for certain
static content. Additionally, if you
have users all over the globe and your
servers are say located all over in
California, a request for a big file
from, I don't know, say India is going
to take forever. So this is kind of
where CDNs come in.
CDNs are basically just a special type
of cache that is geographically
distributed. Uh generally speaking, your
normal cache is probably in your data
centers. However, CDNs are located all
over the world so that they can actually
be on the edge and serve the content
close to where the users are actually
located. So in order to kind of best
utilize these, what you probably want to
do is partition your content in a way
such that um you know data that is most
likely to be used by certain regions is
going to the particular CDN. So say if
you're a news site, you know, maybe you
want your American news in the America
CDN, but then you know your Indian news
in the CDN for Asia. Uh CDN's can also
be either push or pull based. So of
course obviously if you're pushing your
data to the CDN, what it basically means
is that your server is going to make a
request to the CDN, probably just some
sort of push request that is going to
periodically send data to be stored in
it. So what type of use cases is this
for? Well, this is good when you know
exactly what content users should be
receiving for a certain period of time.
So, for example, you know, if you're a
news site like the New York Times and
once a day you're kind of uploading um
that new front front paper or front
section, you can put the front section
into that CDN via a cron job once per
day. However, there's also an option for
a pull CDN. Pulse CDNs are more similar
to caches in the sense that first the
user is going to hit the cache and if
there's a cache miss then you're going
to hit the server from the CDN to
actually get the content that you want.
This is really good for any type of you
know social media site where certain
images are going to be trending for you
know a decent amount of time which you
can't really predict and then people are
going to kind of stop caring about them
after they've all seen it. So, for
example, you know, if a really new
popular Tik Tok from Justin Bieber comes
out or something and millions of people
from the US want it, they're going to
hit the America CDN and that's
eventually going to be getting a ton of
cash hits and then eventually everyone's
going to have seen that image. They're
not going to need it anymore and then
they'll start requesting for other
things from that CDN and it's going to
pull the new information.
Okay. In terms of actually visualizing
these CDNs, um we have you know as you
can see this orange or uh origin server
which is basically just the application
server which is going to be located
somewhere in Asia. And then similarly we
have all of these globally distributed
CDNs which can help users all over the
globe receive their content faster. I
should also quickly mention just because
I um kind of left it out that you know
if a CDN is serving stale data you can
use something like an expiration time or
sometimes even manually purge the data
in order to get it out of there. Okay,
so let's analyze you know the pros and
cons of a CDN because I've been talking
about these things and in any systems
design interview you kind of want to
break down the um benefits and drawbacks
of a given strategy. Um, so here in
general, the pros tend to greatly
outweigh the cons, which is why they're
so popularly used. But the pros are they
greatly reduce the load on your
application servers for popular content
and also big files. So obviously, we
don't want our application servers
crashing because they're just being
hammered. So CDNs can help reduce that.
They can also protect against things
like DOS attacks by acting as some sort
of reverse proxy between the client and
the servers. Um I haven't really covered
reverse proxies yet, but basically just
think of the CDN as a wall of defense
between a potentially malicious client
and a server. Additionally, um they
greatly increase speed to users around
the world. This is because they are
geographically located closer to the
user. That's called like um you know
storing data on the edge. The biggest
cons of CDNs are that um you can
occasionally serve stale data and like I
said, we can kind of try and mitigate
that using any of the cache consistency
strategies that we've discussed. You can
also do it via basically just putting an
expiration time on the data in there.
But additionally, if there are cache
misses, that's going to slow down any
request because we're going to have to
hit the CDN first before trying to
actually hit our server. Um, the second
con, and this is kind of just more of an
operational thing, but it's something to
keep in mind, is that your URLs are now
going to actually be located on the CDN
itself. So any content that's being
stored in the CDN, you generally have to
change the static URLs in the database
to kind of represent the fact that those
files are temporarily being cached in
the CDN and to actually access them from
there instead. I guess in theory you
could, you know, try hitting the CDN
first and then maybe it would pull data
in, but I'm pretty sure you have to go
ahead and change those static URLs.
Okay, so in conclusion, pretty much any
single website that you you're using
these days that is like an actual
company and not just developed by an
individual person with little experience
is probably using a CDN. That's because
they have tons of HTML files to serve
which are static. Probably tons of
images and probably tons of video
content as well. All of which they want
to be able to be accessed quickly and
also accessed in a manner that doesn't
overload their servers. As a result, CN
CDNs are pretty much a guaranteed good
option for any type of website at scale
in terms of tackling these problems.
Like I've said, caching and CDNs in
general are just kind of a huge
necessity for large websites in order to
ensure good performance for a variety of
users. And as a result, you should
always use one if you can. All right,
I'll uh see you guys in the next video.
I don't really know what I'm going to
cover yet, but I'll figure it out by
tomorrow, hopefully.